si vous croisez ceux petits carrés
colorés aux alentours de la gare de
versailles chantiers
il s'agit d'un qr codes de
l'expérimentation la vilaine ce
dispositif vise à aider les personnes
atteintes de déficience visuelle
kerbellec malvoyantes est l'application
14 marche puis palier +13 marche tout en
haut
scannez le code à vos pieds cette
technologie peut bien aidé à la
personnes malvoyantes ou non voyantes
dans le dans le sens que nous on sait
vers où aller et d'avoir les
enseignements si on est bien sur le
chemin qu'on veut pas pourrir le
parcours a été étudié pour être le plus
instinctif possible des arrêts de bus en
dehors de la gare jusqu'au quai
intersection une fois à l'intersection
portique de validation devant formation
sncf à 10h et l'information voyageurs
aujourd'hui pour s'assurer que les
usagers profitent pleinement de cette
qualité de transport c'est devenu
quelque chose d'essentiel
et parmi l'information voyageur il ya le
sujet de l'inclusivité qui est parfois
difficile à dresser et kiên à vilain
cela pour le coup nous apporte une
solution qui me semblait très
intéressante a attesté développé par
versailles grand parc et la société
keolis le dispositif pourrait être
élargie à d'autres usages en cas de
réussite de la phase de test mi juillet
la logi des des clients occasionnels des
touristes qui pourrait tout à fait
utiliser cette solution
suite à ces besoins
quant aux testeurs il a déjà soumis
quelques axes d'amélioration il
souhaiterait une indication du numéro du
bus qui arrive est un système
miniaturisés pour moi attiré l'oeil des
autres passants